okay since I'm underwriting the cost can
I take a bit of Liberty with all of you
how bout we do a wave it's Saturday
morning come on it's it's a boring
dreary Saturday morning so let's do this
let's let's try and do a wave to just
get started off i'm going to say python
data science rocks okay so all of you
guys here on that role you know when I
say Python get up into a Python as loud
as you can okay great and this role here
is guys get up when I say data science
get up and say data science as loud as
you can okay and all of you here when I
say rocks you guys get up say rocks as
loud as you can okay are we going to do
it like three times come on I don't know
if you have you ever had a Python
conference where you did a wave let's do
it let's make the 11 pi day to the one
where that happens okay python data
science rah rah by then de design
by then Dana science rah awesome gears
of a hat okay so that's fun so it was
only about four years ago that Marc
Andreessen said software is eating the
world he meant software is in the fabric
of our everyday lives but no you know
something that magical has happened in
the cloud is eating software all types
of software are being delivered on the
cloudless services and all of us in the
cutting edge like most of you in the
audience know that's where software is
going but there's something else that's
happening something else that's equally
important the cloud is eating data when
a cloud seeding software and then all
the data in the world flows into the
cloud and the cloud eats data when it
died just both you get intelligence it's
not necessarily intelligence like in the
human brain but it's a kind of
intelligence that makes things around us
intelligent and smart in so many
different ways so let me tell you what I
mean okay so once upon a time all the
world's data was analog you know two and
a half Zita bites of it books gramophone
records and all of that well that was
not too long ago that 30 years ago and
then client-server computing came and
the internet came and the digital data
exploded and started overtaking analog
so that blue area that's the digital
data that's starting to happen again it
was not too long ago and then the data
on connected devices grew data now had
an IP address this is collected data for
the first time data was addressable okay
the vast majority of the world's data
now is completely digital there are
about 10 0 bytes of it and that's by the
way 10 million petabytes and connected
data is taking over and this is 2015 you
see analog has disappeared practically
speaking or it is disappearing as a
fraction of overall data and the
majority of that data is now digital and
at least half of that is connected data
living in the cloud and in data centers
and fast-forward 20 20
by 2020 there will be about 50 0 bytes
of data 15 million petabytes that's data
from the internet of things from your
mobile devices it's audio media sensor
data and the vast majority of that data
is an interconnected data centers
internet-connected data centers it's in
the cloud right and that's where the
planets information and intelligence
will decide and by the way all of that
data is right next to extremely
sophisticated software algorithms and
big data systems and that transformation
is revolutionising every industry okay
so when we have conversations with
developers about this about this
transformation developers like yourself
what to do about four different things
with all of that data you want to first
really understand what happened in the
past by looking at the data and doing
retrospective analysis on it well then
very often you want to actually do
real-time analytics on because real-time
data is in fact many in many ways more
valuable than old historical data and
you want to know what's happening right
now if you're on the road you want to
know where the traffic issues are right
real time and then they actually want to
look at the patterns in the past and
extrapolate for the future and hopefully
you want to do that in a scientific way
predictive analytics and then they
finally want to build internet in apps
with it and like most of you really are
about building applications that
actually take an action as opposed to
just sitting around analyzing past data
and you want to build intelligence as
apps okay so and all of this in the
cloud is becoming dramatically easier
and faster in the best way for me to
illustrate this is with a story okay so
I'm going to tell you about the
connected count there's such a thing as
a connected cup it's perhaps a sexier
story in the world it's about the
Internet of Things it's about data it's
about analytics it's about the cloud but
it is also about human ingenuity and how
even the power of data and analytics and
Internet of Things can show up even in
the most surprising places so let me
tell you what I mean these
the connected cows that I'm talking
about notice those parameters on their
legs they are actually counting the
steps that a cow's taking they connected
to Wi-Fi they're sending that data to
Microsoft's cloud Azure and there's a
service in the cloud that analyzes the
data and I have one of those parameters
with me that's actually going to wear it
and walk around but you won't be able to
see it back so this one but but but why
I mean the cows need to take 10,000
steps a day to before I give you the
answer let me step back a second you
know these days every company is a data
company even the ones you least expect
even their reforms for example daily
forms have all the constraints of a
modern business they have a fixed herd
right there cause they have a pasture
they have you know food their output is
milk and beef and they have to maximize
that output under the constraints of
expensive farm labor and a fixed heard
and the pass room they have so what's a
farmer to do what a dairy farmer can do
is a couple of eggs they can detect
health issues and cows early and prevent
loss of the hood or they can improve
cattle production by accurate detection
of estrus now if you remember high
school biology estrus is when the animal
goes into heat when the animal is ready
to mate you know when the time is right
so to speak and that's the only time
when animals are ready to reproduce and
so how can a farmer tell when the time
is right for hundreds of cows in a dairy
farm good technology how could you for
example build a heatmap ordinary form so
to speak
well to see how important accurate it is
estrous detection is let me actually
show you data from a research paper you
know this is serious stuff by the way
these days with artificial insemination
the conception rate is actually
relatively high it's about seventy
percent it's on the left but you know
estrous detection rate is that second
column it's about fifty-five percent and
if you multiply the two you get a
pregnancy rate about thirty-nine percent
now estrous detection is done by age old
methods and methods that haven't really
changed for a millennia and three at the
end of the day close observation you
just need very you know farmhands to go
and see if the animal is going in a heap
and so now if you look at the multiply
the two things together you see the
probability is actually pretty low but
good technology really help and push
that estrous detection rate up to ninety
five percent if we can do that you get
up to a 66 person improvement in
pregnancy rate and calf production in
their dairy farm and that's actually
incredibly materially important to the
farm okay so but this is hard right this
is hard for a couple of reasons you know
estrus lasts only about 12 to 18 hours
every 21 days and those numbers are very
variable it's not always 21 days it
changes and when it I see it turns out
and what's actually going to heat only
when conditions are safe and they feel
secure and all of those things right and
of course mostly between 10pm an 8am
like a lot of these things and it is
hard in some ways to accurately detect
that so how can farmers term when the
time is right so that was a question a
japanese former asked one of our
partners fujitsu and fujitsu's engineers
consulted some dairy researchers and
based upon some research that had been
published you know starting from about
2005 they came up with a great system
for detecting he there was ninety-five
percent accurate indeed in fact it is a
hotter system for detecting heat well
this is that system the fujitsu you hoe
how step service or microsoft azure
so the step count data from those
parameters is send over a wireless
receiver and over the Internet to a sure
that's the service on Azure which
analyzes the data and produces alerts
for the farmer on its mobile phone for
each cow so when the cow goes in the
heat the farmer gets an alert and he can
act on it and so there's a secret to
that data scientist will like it let me
tell you what that is so the x-axis on
that graph is a time of night y axis is
the number of steps the cow is taking ok
so this is a normal cow on a normal
night you know sort of just walking
around a little bit lying down and so on
let's see what happens when the animal
goes on the heat the number of steps the
animal takes just shot up way up right
and that's the start of estrus and it's
a ninety-five percent accurate detection
all you have to do is and you're over
here in ordinary day / day count of the
number of steps being taken on our by
the animal at the same time and you can
get a pretty accurate detection they do
a little bit more than that but you can
get a very good accurate detection the
optimal time for artificial insemination
for maximum conception rate is 16 hours
after that that's when AI meets AI
artificial insemination nice now footage
the researchers found another
fascinating thing there's a window of
time around that 16 hours if you perform
artificial insemination the first four
hours you're likely to get a female and
if you perform artificial Spanish in the
second four hours you're likely to get a
male calf amazing with seventy percent
probability by the way it's not all
exact but now the farmer has an amazing
control which you can use to to decide
whether to have more females or males or
milk or beef and Fujitsu's researchers
found even more amazing things when
analyzing that pedal metadata they found
that they could detect about eight
different diseases of cows because when
counselor of different diseases they
have
patterns of restlessness and times of
poisons and so on so they can detect
about eight different diseases and then
remember I said this is about
ninety-five percent accurate that
five-person that a false positive that
turns out to be meaningful as well some
of that is when the cow skips the farm
and runs away important to detect as
well now this by the way has many of you
developers know it's not necessarily
overly sophisticated this kind of a
system with today's cloud-based services
most many of you can actually build in
hours and the power of the cloud is that
once you build a service like that you
can make it global with very very little
effort so when you build something
amazing when you discover something very
interesting like that in data the time
from discovering that they're having a
product that global and distributed and
even farmers all over the world can use
is extremely short that's agility and
magic of the clock now I thought this
was a great story and then we went to
Israel and we found that the series had
taken this to a whole new level by the
way mr. ian has the world's largest per
capita production of milk three times
what any other countries he achieves all
through the use of technology that's
really literally an Internet of cows and
here are some of the companies that are
doing it here is a company called SCR
that provides a whole herd management a
tool with with great dashboards on your
mobile phones there is a company called
a free milk that that's actually
significant optimization of the entire
process from milking to actually create
it in a making cheese and dairy products
and how to make it in the most optimal
fashion and they are again using the
cloud by the way these are all cloud
partners and yet another one is a call
which is a Israel's dairy network and
they cover all of these things growers
and farmers quality dairy cooperatives
treatment suppliers all of that using
cloud and cloud-based data because cloud
enables incredible distribution
abilities right imagine dairy farmers
they don't want to maintain servers they
don't
the program things they just want a
service and you can build services that
reach to every part of the world's
economy and revolutionize it that is the
power of the cloud in fact you know
berries are literally milking the club
ok so let's step back now back to the
thread of conversation so now let's talk
about real-time analytics so connected
data by the way it's not only massive
these days it's constantly in motion the
natural state by the way of data now is
in motion it's not on tape sitting still
and data is from sensors from websites
from apps in the cloud from social apps
new types of data being created every
day and it's streaming or the wire in
developers like you want to easily
process that data in real time and get
inside they can use so let's take an
example of a solution that does that on
a sure can example demo in this case and
you said illustrate the power of
developing in the club now how many of
you have seen how old r net out of
curiosity ok good as some of you this
was a demo that i created for a talk and
april it's called yeah how old are net
demo and we will see what that is so
we're going to show you that demo and
you're all going to actually bring the
data in motion to see if we can make a
difference right so take out your phones
it's ok just keep them in in a silent
mode but let's see if you can go to the
URL how'd a shoulder and I'll sure talk
about this so we built this app using
some of the intelligent ApS we have in
the club right so we have api's in the
gallery asher ml gallery for face
detection for vision for speech for text
and eggs so by the way to explain all of
this i have my partner in crime chris i
want to say chris rock but crazy
scribble counts but so chris is going to
help me
do this demo with me so Chris let's see
that face API so the face API allows you
to go analyze detect faces and images
analyze them and actually detect the age
and gender from faces okay facemate so
let's now go bring that site how old or
not we actually created a fun
application with that so let's let's
actually I take a look at a couple of
pictures in there so Chris just took a
picture of that beautiful family the you
know you can see it detected the age and
gender of people in that picture you
know the grandpa looks about 73 the kids
look about 15 and seven you know very
nice so Chris I McCamey take some
picture from the web let's say Mona Lisa
and let's see how old she looks so I so
she is 24 in fact when Leonardo painted
that model she was actually about 24 so
why do you all take some selfies or
pictures try and uploading it okay and
you know see if it's working for you so
let's Chris let's take some picture and
try it out so that's by the way the team
that built hawaldar net took them only a
couple of days of work really to
actually build it and so 34 35 30 now
it's lying about quorum he's a chief
developer he's actually about 37 but you
know hey he it's about how old he looks
in that picture and we can see that now
if Chris uploads this picture Chris I
think you have a fun picture up there so
this is chris same age with a beard
without a beard well so you know he
talked to his wife yesterday his wife
confirmed that he actually indeed to her
looks 12 when he is locked well so try
this and so the thing is what we're
doing with this is we actually are
collecting a lot of the data from that
website to build analytics on top of it
so we have you know Jason I being
captured from it so yeah let's see let's
actually show the kind of day
we are collecting the user agent string
we are collecting the date and time we
got the location the latitude and
longitude and of course the age that's
being collected and so that live data is
being captured as we speak and you're
showing it on a dashboard okay so let's
go to the dashboard so the this is a the
live dashboard by the way let's go to
the top by the way so this we have had
70 8.5 million users use that site from
the time we launched in April we had 552
million photos uploaded it went viral on
twitter by the way as we did it and
number of faces in the last 60 seconds
is 315 so actually you know you might be
able to make a difference if you
actually just tried it all at once you
might see that actually move that graph
that faces by browser and move maybe
maybe 12 maybe it won't okay so let's
let's take that dashboard Chris can you
click on that maybe you can ask a
natural language question this dashboard
allows you to ask questions in natural
language this is a power bi dashboard
hoster onager ok it allows you to taken
data you know he said yeah number of
phases in the last 120 seconds by
browser and date in a bar chart you got
a bar chart the power of power bi as a
service is that you can interact with
all of that data in natural language it
makes it very easy for a business user
now it's not oriented necessary for
developers there are two scenarios
producing dashboards for business users
and producing dashboards when you and I
are developing things when you're
developing things you want something
much more interactive of course but this
is a great tool and that by the way is
the location from which people are
actually uploading paces so now let's go
back let's go back and look at that live
streaming chart yeah so that dashboard
that is life faces by browser you know
it's actually the number of faces being
uploaded from every type of browser
now people like you know how hard it is
to create those kinds of life dashboards
right live data streaming in and you
want the graphs to move and all of that
it's actually a lot of coding now we
have great services in a sure that
simplifies it fully managed services
there's a service called actual stream
analytics okay and the way we build
these things is we bring data through
even hubs even hubs allows you to ingest
streaming data it's a fully managed
service on the cloud you know or not we
install any software it just right to it
data comes into the cloud and then from
even hubs you can use a show stream
analytics to configure standing queries
in the stream of data that produce those
kind of analysis that you can plot in
power bi okay and let's show you that
query and what's magical about stream
analytics is how simple it makes that
code so this is the code that just
aggregates the computation for that
streaming dashboard basically counting
you know you can you can all understand
it it's eight lines of code to count for
each browser type the number of faces
being uploaded from the stream input
aggregate it over at 10 second time
window using a hopping window okay eight
lines of code and you have that
aggregation done imagine how many lines
of code it will take in Java and storm
it's actually about you know how several
hundreds of lines in human in Python it
will take quite a lot of coding and you
let it compile and run it and so on and
set up you don't know how to do any of
that so this is in a streaming data
you're able to actually just put the
query in and it will just work okay so
that's the magic of streaming amarixe so
now look we started by talking about
data in motion and what you've just seen
is how you can analyze data and motion
with stream analytics and build great
dashboards with power bi all of that in
a very very short time frame if you know
what you're doing okay it's incredibly
powerful so we have covered real
turmeric now let's talk about predictive
analytics so this is the other greatest
area of interest machine learning
predictive analytics and all that
by the way let me ask this audience a
question how many of you know who
invented the least squares algorithm
that is so fundamental regression and
predictive analytics okay in the back
cows cows at what age yeah he was a
friend he said is 17 essentially 18 you
know in the back in the 18th century he
was 18 years old and what was the big
data he was studying at that time
anybody know what no he was I could go
back there what here's track in common
actually there was not true what he was
just was doing here he was he was just
looking at planetary motion he was just
looking into the sky he had all the data
points of where the planets were at
different times of the year and he
wanted to actually figure out what the
path these planets were following so you
have a really squirrel spit and he
invented village squares algorithm at
the tender age of 18 he was curious in
this part and so now what's happened
these days is because we have so much
amazing data being collected from every
aspects of our lives you can apply even
simple statistical techniques but here
you do it at scale and you can get
magical results out of that now we have
in you know in February we have a
service called a show machine learning
that be announced as general
availability right it is a
state-of-the-art service or fully
managed in the cloud that allows
incredibly comprehensive machine
learning models to be built and not only
can you build them in the cloud but you
can deploy them as api's and that's
incredibly important now how many of you
actually do data science for a living
okay a lot of you do most of you I bet
believe that the hardest thing in data
science is actually doing the data
wrangling like bringing the data in and
you know understanding word works and by
the way I've done data sent for 20 years
as well and I agree that that is
actually hard but think about deploying
a machine learning model that you built
in production at scale in a nap and
managing it and maintaining it and how
much work that is the vast majority of
data scientists today actually don't
have to deal with that struggle because
they outsource it to IT and it takes
them months to do it and unless you have
already built in your enterprise a great
architecture for managing machine
learning models and ways to update it at
ways to actually audited and ways to do
a be testing it ways to do champion
Challenger and if you haven't done all
of that if you have none of that yeah
okay you have a better infrastructure
but that's hard work most people can do
that now what we have done with Azure
machine learning is made it incredibly
simple to build machine learning models
and publish it as a web service API all
hosted in the cloud it runs in the cloud
and it's actually extremely easy to
integrate it into applications ok so
again the best way for me to tell you
and show you this is through a story now
for those of you who are sort of from
outside the US there is something we'll
march madness that happens in March here
in the US it's the NCAA college college
basketball games and it's a time when
Americans love to gamble everyone has a
prediction about who's going to win and
people actually make serious bets and it
feels like everyone has a has a
prediction to make even you know our old
president who had created a great
bracket Satya Nadella our CEO actually
he surprised the world sort of by
picking March Madness winners better
than being and better than most people
now Google had predictions bring her
predictions now softly had predictions
thought they had by the way help I have
from people data scientists and people
who knew basketball but but how many now
tell you a story about Adam garment Adam
garland is a developer in office okay he
didn't know very much about basketball
body thought it would be actually really
fun to use a hackathon we had kicked off
at that time okay we had done a march
madness competition and aren't I sure
Emma I thought it would be fun to use
that as an opportunity to learn machine
learning and within a few hours here
taken the data set of teams that were
competing in
winning and I had built a great
predictive model and I refined it a
little bit and he did much better than
Google's predictions banks predictions
and even sucked his predictions he came
absolutely number one and it was not
just him many of the people who
participated in our internal hackathon
they more than lot of them came fairly
close to the top you see all those
machine learning things and they came
pretty high up in the ranks and so I
thought it might be actually fun to show
you what Adam garland dead and recreate
what he did so that you can see how easy
it is to make that happen so to predict
if a team will win or lose typically i
need a binary classifier okay so I'm
going to say two teams which one will
win well the team one win or not okay
let's start with the sample from the
azure ml gallery chris is doing that now
and let's open that in studio so the
thing about by the way the gallery is
there are lots of sample experiments
there that can be with a click opened in
the ashram else to do and it's live
ready for to be wrong so this is a
classic workflow for a binary classifier
you can see it's very simple you read
the data you clean the missing data you
select the columns you want then there
is a two-class boosted decision tree
that we are going to train okay and then
we are going to score the model with
that trained to class boosted decision
tree and evaluate the model very simple
workflow for a typical binary classifier
it's there if you want to modify that
you can modify that too so Chris let's
run it let's just run it if you can yeah
that's yeah so we can easily modify that
workflow bring in the NCAA historical
matches right he can modify that bigger
put that in and he just ran that
workflow and while that's running let's
go look at the data we can actually
click on the data set and visualize it
and so this is the historical data on
matches 20 years of basketball games and
it shows you hey the teams that played
each other you know the stats when he
clicks on score one it shows the
statistics on
that one we scroll a little bit to the
right on the Left table yeah you can see
the other types of data it's basically
very simple data so two teams played
each other and the last column says
weather team 11 or not okay and so you
get a true false that's your target that
you're trying to predict extremely
simple data for now so let's go back and
see how this model performed so that
experiment run and now when you
visualize it you will see the ROC curve
the ROC curve quality shows how good it
is we have got about a 63 / % area I
accuracy in prediction okay not too bad
for that kind of sparse data all you
have as matches that have been played
okay so that's what you have so now
let's go back and see what Adam did Adam
actually did something a little bit more
after doing that first thing he brought
in more data he brought in team
performance and average annual team
stats so there were historical matches
and he then brought in team stats and
merged them and he joined them with a
little bit of sequel he also did a two
class boosted decision tree the two
class actually a decision jungle to
class decision jungle and then he did a
sweeping of parameters he tried all the
parameters available he ran a sweep and
there he picked the best okay so that's
what he did so again let's run it but we
while let's now actually go look at that
data in a way that is more familiar to
many of you using a Python notebook so
what we are going to actually show it's
actually something pretty cool now
shadow can team here build a great
ipython notebook service on a sure it's
fully hosted okay you don't it's not
actually going to run on a laptop it's
fully integrated national demo you can
actually fire up and I Python notebook
from any of those nodes in the graph
bring that up data up and interact with
it so I'm going to actually let Chris
now go solo and show us the magic of the
ipython notebook hostile and natural so
I've already opened the notebook here
and by default we give you the first
cell filled in so what we've done is
we've used an azure ml python package
that's up on PI P right now pulled in
your workspace ID as well as
authorization token and given you the
data set as a pandas dataframe so we can
run this and it's going to download the
data into this Jupiter notebook we can
visualize the frame now for those of you
that don't know what a data frame is in
pandas you can always put a question
mark after it we can control enter look
at some helpful information that'll kind
of give us an idea of the shape of our
data and some information on how we use
a pandas dataframe we also have an all
right intellisense set up where we can
describe that's what I wanted to do so
we're going to go ahead and describe
this data and it collapse the help here
and we now can see some statistical
information about the different data
columns we have we can also do things
like filter the data a bit so I'm
interested in my favorite team which is
Wisconsin so we're that's where I come
from so we can now see wherever the team
is Wisconsin we can see all of their
stats over the years and sort of get an
idea of what kind of play they do we
also easily plot the information we can
say let's do team on the x-axis and
let's do score on the other we can kind
of get an idea of where an average
basketball score might lie we can see
it's pretty level across the whole thing
and this is really the tip of the
iceberg what you can do with the Jupiter
notebook this already has over 300
packages it's using an anaconda distro
already for you so you can do
scikit-learn you can use numpy you can
use pandas all the tools you're familiar
with in the cloud in the same data
centers your data it'll be faster it'll
be cheaper and it's a great playground
it's it's really fun yeah and Jupiter
notebooks here by the way in the future
will include are in it we will actually
have other kernels that work in it so
this is going to provide an incredible
rapel environment right there in the
cloud right next to the data so that
data scientists can very very easily
interact with the data create the models
then of course the next big step is
actually to deploy the models in the
cloud so let me actually show you how to
actually deploy the model in the cloud
so Chris so let's go publish this as a
web service yeah so what he did is he
clicked up on set up as a web service
and automatically that graph transformed
itself to a sample that you would use to
publish an API remember when you are
actually publishing an application it's
not the same workflow as the modeling
workflow you need to take the model that
is trained in this particular case the
model became at the top left yeah that's
the model and then right and then you
have the web service input the data
transformations happen the train model
is picked up you're using the scoring
with it and Chris if you scroll down you
will see then the web service output
right so the on the left here that this
became this is the model you score in
the model and you're providing the web
service output right so this is the
scoring workflow so you can go from a
modeling work flow or the
experimentation workflow to a scoring
workflow and you can modify that you can
actually bring in other modules if you
wanted to put in an execute python
module right in there that does some
transformations additional
transformations and especially take the
score and do additional transformations
and combine it with other information
you can put that all in there before you
actually pump it to the web service
output so now Asher ml allows you to
build a complete ml application it's not
about just an experimentation platform
it allows you to create a complete ml
application and create and web hoster
account hosted API using this right so
now let's actually publish the web
service and when Chris publishes the web
service at Live API is being created in
Azure and it is hosted in the it's a
REST API it's hosted it's all data
interfaces you just saw that happen this
is
all it took to publish and an API in the
cloud it's elastic it is scalable it's
ready to be integrated in applications
it can be run a call from mobile phones
can be called from Python notebooks can
we call from anywhere so that changes
the game by the way in
operationalization production by the way
this also is the best tool that I know
of or the fastest tool I know of for you
to operationalize Python code remember
it doesn't have to be machine learning
you can bring in arbitrary Python code
put that in an execute Python script and
go through that workflow and publish an
API and a Python code is hosted in the
cloud and ready to be integrated and
call them from applications so now that
API key is shown right there at the top
let's go look at a health page Chris
yeah that's the API key let's go there's
a half page that shows you how to call
this so if you see you'll see the URL de
of that rest api if you go scroll all
the way down you would see the sample
code you will see the sample code in in
all the way down now it's fairly close
there you go so you have b'av
automatically generate sample code in C
sharp in Python pick like Python you
will see the sample code you know you
can basically see the API key there here
there is ABC 123 if you replace that
with that key that was shown you can
actually execute and call that right and
so let's now actually do that Christa
when we just bring up an ipod a jupiter
notebook and show how to actually call
that web service live sure so i'm going
to go back here to the machine learning
home page here and we have a notebook
stab and i have a notebook for consuming
a service the nice thing about the
machine learning environment too is you
don't always have to be in jupiter to
see them any time you log into studio
any notebook you've opened before will
be listed there with a timestamp who
created it you can also share these
around within workspaces so here we have
some basic code we use again the azure
ml library we've published and there are
some handy decorators we can use to make
a team one wins function so here we can
provide the API URL and key we provide
the types that are needed so we're going
to need to round ass eaten team ID for
each team playing
we need to know the input name which in
this case is math and the output name
which is prediction and we can provide
an empty method and we'll take care of
it for you so let's run this and then
down here we're going to call team one
wins and in round six of the 2015 Final
Four Duke and Wisconsin played each
other they're both the first seed I'm
going to do some string formatting here
and we're going to see who won and how
sure the algorithm is of it so it says
Duke Wins with a probability of
fifty-four percent how do you feel about
that Chris less than good but certainly
54m in just slightly over even odds but
that's exactly what item garland did I
mean he built that model he predicted do
you could win and he scored the highest
in rank and in the hackathon so this is
again the magic of the cloud hosted
operationalization and development so
you saw how we went all the way from
data to a finish web service that can be
integrated in any web api into any web
site into mobile applications into
Jupiter notebooks and get results so
these Jupiter notebooks by the way now
if you go to ashram of studio can we
actually go back to Asha Ramos video
Chris and you know can you actually
select the notebooks tab and so this is
a note books tab you can see the
notebooks that you've created if you
click + new by the way down below you
can actually all see notebooks you can
start with different kinds of notebooks
so remember these notebooks are actually
saved in natural rubber studio so you
can create experiments using notebooks
save them and that's all there it's
actually pretty magical it can have a
pretty complex experiment all set up in
the notebook and you I can save them you
can share them and so on so this is
actually a great feature so now let's
let's go back it's a let's step back to
the slides so I just want to step back a
little bit and we showed you with
operationalization how to go create
something that can be integrated no
applications when you think about going
from data to actions there are typically
several things that people want to do
you know
first people ask when they see the data
what happened okay in the past and then
they think about what happened a little
bit there's a manual process that you go
through before you make a decision or
the data and drive some action okay if
you're a little bit smarter
statistically smarter and you have some
data scientists you will actually go up
and say hey why did that thing happen ok
you're going bit up beyond business
intelligence slice and dice you're
actually asking why it happened then you
actually think on it a little bit and
say hey okay knowing now why it happened
i'm going to actually take a decision
and then drive an action now actually
what you need to do a little bit more if
you're intelligent is to model what will
happen using data and using scientific
method you in fact using a/b testing and
a property to validate the process then
you take hey more informed decisions
because you know what the future is like
and then if you're really smart you're
going to expect the algorithms to tell
you what you should do ideally you want
a prescription you actually get a recipe
and then you can actually go straight to
the decision or action or create
automated systems that go end-to-end and
drive a completely automated intelligent
process that's the ultimate goal of all
the intelligent apps that we build you
want to actually a complete process to
be intelligent okay cool so enter the
quarter and analytics suite when we
thought about all of what it takes to go
from later to intelligent action we felt
we really have to bring together a lot
of different components it is not just
about machine learning and putting a web
service in the cloud that is an
important piece of it but it's a lot
more required you need information
management you need to be able to bring
data in from a wide variety of sources
very simply and easily and information
integration by the way is key to
intelligence most smart applications
become smart not just because of the
power of one algorithm it's not deep
neural networks that or create
intelligence for example it's when you
bring lots of different types of data
together combine them together and apply
algorithms on top of the integrated data
and so to do a lot of that by the way
you do need
big data stores so we have a sure has a
number of big data stores and then
machine learning and analytics and a lot
of you as you saw would also want
powerful dashboards and visualizations
and pre-configured solutions on top and
we also had great technology for
perceptual intelligence and why is that
important if you think about most of the
data that's being created in the world
today a lot of that is completely
unstructured data it is images it is
face data it is a speech and video and
its data from sensors so you want to be
able to manage all of that and not only
that use all of that intelligently but
when you actually build an application
wouldn't it be nice if you had an
intelligent interface to that an
interface with which you could ask
questions in natural language instead of
typing sequel queries or writing Python
code an interface that was proactive and
could alert you when something happens
in the data and interface that actually
allowed you to configure smart things
that you want to get to know and
understood the context in which you are
asking questions and that's Cortana
Cortana is a is Microsoft's personal
digital assistant it's on Windows Phones
now but very soon will be on every
Windows 10 machine we're going to have a
billion billion laptops in about two to
three years that have Cortana on it can
you use code on the interface to
interact with enterprise data and so
when we brought all these things
together we also realized we could
integrate them with great solutions
templates and so on that's the Cortana
analytics suite okay so here at law all
the components in it remember analytics
is actually a lot of different things we
have brought in era of things like I
should data factory that allows you to
orchestrate data movement across
different services and fire of different
services we have a sure data catalog to
catalog the data we have big data stores
like asteroid data lake and sequel data
warehouse in which you can do big data
computation we have machine learning and
analytics and we have dashboards and
visualizations it's a lot of components
but integrated as a suite with templates
recipes and
Solutions the best way for me to again
illustrate this and show you the power
of it is by taking a real-world
application okay we are working with the
Dartmouth Hitchcock hospital and I let
the public health care system is
challenged by the task to deliver
exceptional personalized care and a
lower cost despite spending nearly
one-fifth of our gross domestic product
on healthcare we struggle to meet this
goal financial pressures on care
providers are increasing this isn't
sustainable so how can we deliver high
quality personalized care that patients
deserve given the cost pressures we face
at dartmouth-hitchcock we've created
imagined care a new cloud-based solution
built on Cortana analytics suite and
Microsoft Dynamics that enables
providers to help patients achieve
better health with the help of Microsoft
acute dartmouth-hitchcock is building a
technology platform to serve healthcare
organizations and patients across the
country setting a new standard for
personalized care now using machine
intelligence providers can develop a
care plan that's unique to each patient
we can monitor patients from their homes
where data is collected from devices and
sent to the cloud to imagine cares 24-7
contact center where registered nurses
continually monitor a patient's health
status and potentially serious trends
Cortana summarize health status for ben
andrews ben andrews weight has increased
more than 2 pounds in the last 24 hours
please review the home diaeresis
protocol prescribed by dr. Phillips
patients get reminders and encouragement
and dynamic updates to their care plans
improving their health helping them
avoid unnecessary trips to the emergency
room and reducing the cost of care with
support from loved ones and real-time
interventions there is less likelihood
of readmission
with Cortana analytics suite and
Microsoft Dynamics we're transforming
the way health care is delivered today
improving patient outcomes reducing
costs and offering an unprecedented
level of personalized care I remember
every hospital these days is a data
company to hospitals traditionally have
used all types of mechanisms to treat
patients after they had an incident in
the future world is going to be
different you're going to use data from
the Internet of Things from blood
pressure monitors that are connected to
services in the cloud to be able to
actually predict when an event will
happen and you can have proactive health
care to avoid unnecessary emergency room
admissions and unnecessary things that
you can actually totally prevent its
preventive health care in fact in the
future data will be the thing that
changes the healthcare healthcare system
the most by the way this is not new
anybody know who the world's first
female data scientist was anybody in the
audience yes not ada lovelace it was
actually go ahead Florence Nightingale
Florence Nightingale used data from
hospital conditions during the Crimean
War she created the very first circle of
histogram by the way and showed that
more people died of hospital infections
than in the battlefield and that was the
primary driver for sanitation in
hospitals the big change that happened
for sanitation in hospitals and for that
she was elected to the royal statistical
society in the 1930s and became an auto
restitution so that the power of data
was evident even then and in the future
the power of data with predictive
analytics is going to change our lives
so big data and analysts can truly
change lives ok so here's what's
happening now with the intelligent cloud
right the magic of the cloud is the
agility it gives developers and the
integration of data
from all sorts of sources though the
cloud helps turn hardware into software
you don't have to worry about hardware
installation and management and all of
those it's available as a service
hardware's available as a service it
turns software into services you don't
have to worry about installation of
software version control and licensing
and all of those it also turns data into
intelligence it makes you smart it sets
you free and it allows you to go as fast
as you could possibly go so let me
conclude with a story a final story that
in many ways captures the spirit of what
we are trying to do this is a story of
north american eagle and there's a young
man in the video that i'm about to show
you is 20 years old is a sophomore at
u-dub he started in this project at age
16 and he is using data to break land
speed records so let me play that video
and i'll show you what it means
it's human nature to go as fast as you
can possibly go
I'm not afraid of dying I don't want to
die but I'm not afraid of it I'm sure
this moment for all my life I just go
and I don't let up until I have to
on the Eagle there's over 30 sensors
they gather almost 12 million points of
data we want to figure out the best way
in which fits Carter rut enter the
Microsoft cloud we're able to take the
data automatically process it and get
the results in a time frame that was
unimaginable in the past you start
thinking with fear we're gonna be living
with fears and you're not going to be
achieving the goals that you set for
yourself two things that I'm thinking
before I take off let this be a
testament that girls can do anything
they set their mind to and do not wreck
this car
we're processing over 2,000 measurements
a second and that's where machine
learning comes in we're going to be able
to try to find the correlations that are
probably not obvious and drive this
project to a greater extent than we ever
could drink
we will make history in 2015 thank you
all it's going to be a great culture how
should I take one or two questions or is
a we are late on time I think